i love this guy man i'm not just saying
that because he's on hold and he's a
professional and he's on time making his
phone call and it's a point around right
here on the rich eisen show but he is a
walter payton man of the year award
winner and he is a guy right there in
that defensive line for the baltimore
ravens who are three in one could be
easily 4-0 have been through a lot
already in just one month of the season
joining us here before monday night
football against the indianapolis colts
the capper to week five that begins
tonight and the mercedes-benz vans phone
line it is called campbell how are you
kaleas
hey living the dream baby how you doing
i am better for talking to you living
the dream what year is this for you now
calais what year is it 4 14 whoa come on
14
that is crazy
that it's gotta be do you sit back and
think about that at any point like i
can't believe this is year 14 for me
right well most definitely you know
leading to the season you know it kind
of was one of those things where it was
like man you know i had to really sit
back and like
wow you know just take a look at my my
career and uh you know how bad i really
wanted to like got to make a decision do
i really want to go out there and and be
what i could be you know you're 14. and
so uh you know but i worked really hard
got into the position where i feel real
good right now man so you know it's been
fun so you did spend some time uh during
the spring uh or
whenever wondering if you should keep it
going calais yeah yeah yeah i think i
feel like when you get to this level you
have to you know you got to make a
decision you know because this you can't
just kind of do this you know you got to
really make a decision and you know i
have to think about you know all the
different options and you know where my
life is you know where i'm at at this
point in time you know if i really want
to be great at this and so uh i made a
decision and i bust my tail so work
really really hard what is that busting
tail working really hard making sure
you're as great as you can be
in year 14 like walk me through what
that really means class
yeah i would say this off season you
know there's some days where my legs
were heavy and i was just sore as can be
i was tired you know and you have to you
know you have to have a why you know you
have to have a reason for doing it
because you know when i was you know 25
years old i go out there and do my
workouts you know i mean
i felt great you know i had no issues at
all you know i mean you get a little
soreness a little cold tub i'll be fine
versus now you know i mean it's it's a
grind you know i feel
you know the every bit of it and uh then
i have to about to get myself up to a
position where i knew that if i do it
now if i did it in the spring
you know now in this current time i'll
feel good and you know late in the
fourth quarter last week and i felt
great i feel like i was at my best how
about that so let's get to the why why
why you're 14 why do it
why yeah uh okay uh well you know uh
first things first i want to win a super
bowl you know i mean i i i i went to it
as a rookie and you know uh snot nosed
little kid not knowing how precious that
moment was it really was you know i just
couldn't even though everybody told me
that this is rare and appreciated you
know i was just i was 22 you know and i
i i couldn't i couldn't know better
and uh so um you know i i mean
a lot of ups and downs you know a couple
championship games
you know moments away from being in the
super bowl and just haven't been able to
get back
and i want it bad man i feel like this
team and we know what we have i know
we're capable
and then you know i just feel like
you know my career and what i've done
you know um you know i want to be at the
very end of it you know um
you know with a bronze head and uh and
the gold jacket that's always been a big
goal of mine you know i think everybody
who plays this game should have that
goal of being considered the best of the
best when you do it
and um you know i feel like you know i i
would like to leave no doubt and so i
know i got a lot of work to do
so just going back to one more time here
so
the um the super bowl that you were in
just so everyone can understand how how
long it was that super bowl was the one
in in tampa right where yep with with
kurt and
fitz and james harrison and all of that
right that was yours yeah that was my
super bowl what
was
what was that one like for you i've
never asked you about that that's kind
of crazy that feels like a different
life
for me professionally i must feel like
that wait for you
i mean it was a long time ago yeah but
it was i mean i still remember like it
was yesterday because it was such a
special time in my life you know i mean
you think about all the time when i was
a kid and i dreamt about playing the
super bowl and then my first year in the
nfl here comes and like the whole day
the whole week really but that day
leading up to the game i couldn't even
feel my body like i felt like my body
was just like i was floating everywhere
i was just floating i couldn't even feel
my legs
and it wasn't until the game started and
i got that first hit where i was like
okay you know this is just football uh
but it was a incredible experience you
know and uh to be able like i mean it
was just an incredible game for the
people who remember it i mean it went
down to the very last play sure did yeah
sure did doc
i know calais campbell here uh on the
rich eisen show monday night football
colts and ravens so what makes you think
the ravens can win a super bowl what
gives you that sense that feeling
well first things first i think we got a
whole lot of talent in this building you
know and the number one reason is lamar
jackson you know uh he's just an
incredible player that you know just
makes everybody else around him better
and then uh just the brother brotherhood
we have you know i mean this place you
know we really
have that bond where we play for each
other and i believe anytime you play for
each other it's gonna allow you to play
above your potential you know you can
play at the highest level of your
potential when you're when you're doing
it for somebody else that's next to you
and we have that brotherhood so far you
know now obviously you know that's not
enough you know you got to go out there
and execute and make plays you know but
you know we have the guys that can can
make the plays and we're motivated to
make them so now it just comes down to
the execution and the health and all the
different things that go into it but you
know it's a long run but i think
i try to make sure guys understand now
is just be in the moment so the best we
can be today right in terms of that bond
and playing for one another calais
campbell i mean
how did you guys grow
uh to closer together
from that awful day in training camp or
right before the beginning of the season
uh after training camp but right before
the beginning of the season where gus
edwards and marcus peter joe down uh
with knee injuries after dobbins went
down with a knee injury it was just like
it was a it was a rash that completely
blew my mind from just the outside
looking in what about your team and
bonding
through and around all of that
yeah it was um i mean that was a crazy
day you know in all my years of football
i never seen anything like that
you know uh where two your star players
go down within plays of each other you
know i mean it was literally like three
plays later
and like the first time you know you
know when people went down you know he
went out first and then like just takes
the win out of you you know we're having
a great practice we're flying around
we're having fun
and then you know a guy that you just
you know you have so much love for
admiration you know for the way he plays
again the way he you know what he brings
to the game it's just like man you your
heart breaks for him you know because
you know i know our dap i know who we
have stepping up that can make plays i
know we're still going to be a good
football team
but it's just like i know how hard he
worked and like how good of a season he
could have had and just kind of
heartbreak's form
and then like literally a couple players
later you see gus go down and another
guy that i've been a big fan of because
he went to the u and i've been following
square all of it all of his career i've
been following him and just a big fan of
his and just seeing
his development and how he's become just
this you know this this guy was ready to
take over the league i just thought he
could have been all pro this year
and then you know he goes down it's just
like wow you know and then coach called
to practice up and it was just you could
feel the energy you know uh and the
building just kind of gets sucked out
but we got great leaders and great
people who've been through some stuff
you know and
understand that like we couldn't let
that do tourists we had to just come
together and then you know play for them
you know because they still part of this
you know everything we did up until this
point you know they're still a big part
of it and they still come into the
building you know still bring that good
energy in the building still so
which has been great for us
and then you know um
the season opener the monday nighter uh
in in las vegas which was insane it was
like a trip to vegas all in one you know
five quarter football game you know
and um and then
uh that moment in time where you're
staring you know owen two right in the
face with the chiefs just needing to
hold on to the football to win it and
your teammate away comes up with a huge
play how good is this kid and what
you're seeing right next to you on that
line
he's special you know i mean he's just a
young talented kid with a whole lot of
heart
plays hard and um you know i don't think
he even realized how big of a moment
that is i tell him you know but i don't
want to get too big at this i don't make
too big of a deal about it
you know you got to make sure you know
that you know keep keep them humble
and working but his potential is through
the roof
and he has a knack for making plays you
know i mean that's something that like
you know their playing for a field goal
you know
would have been tough tough kicking in
that position you know especially with
the way we rushed the kicker but you
know in that situation it was like man
you know it's gonna be a tough tough
ball getting away unless we make a play
and he comes up with you know play i
mean enforcing foam on recovering it and
that's spectacular and that's something
you can't coach you know it's just
instincts you know just a knack for
making plays
and uh you know special but we have a
lot of guys like that on this team
that's why i feel like we have a real
chance but obviously that's the stuff
you can't you can't do it today all
right to do is take advantage of the
moment in front of you and monday night
football man it's gonna be a tough
matchup so we gotta go out there and be
our best you have a few more minutes
left here with calais campbell on the
rich hazard what did it mean to see
harbaugh i don't know if you if you
heard it at the time but we saw the nbc
cameras on that week two sunday night uh
harbaugh asked lamar if he wanted to go
for it on that fourth down to wrap it up
i mean and obviously you'd have been in
a very difficult position having to
defend against lamar uh patrick mahomes
on a shorter field uh
with with backs against the wall and
needing them only needing a field goal
what did that mean for you to see that
from your coach
yeah i mean so i'll say this you know uh
harb's he's a guy he's a man of his word
you know and he and he has uh his
beliefs and things that mean something
to him and he sticks up for him and i
remember uh when we were practicing in
camp you know and he's talking about you
know uh in those four-for-one situations
when it's a tough ball game you know
what do you guys want
and uh you know you know
everything's situational in a sense but
generally speaking you know i feel like
offense i'm very confident officer can
pick up a yard we're the best running
football team
you know and probably in the history of
the game up there you know uh one of the
best in the history of the game and so
for us you'll get one yard i feel like
it's very doable
uh with the guys we have you know out
there controlling it so you know i felt
pretty good about being able to get that
one yard but then again as a defender
you know when you only got to defend one
you know one yard for one play you know
you sell out and so it's it's definitely
a balance
and uh you know i remember coach took it
to the sideline and you know everybody
inside last night go for it go for it go
for it and he asked lamar you already
know lamar's you know i mean he's
confident in his ability and put the
ball in his hands he's going to make it
happen so it was a crazy moment you know
uh and you know i i personally you know
being a you know trying to be a
strategic person in the game like you
know it's okay we pointed though because
i know our defense can go out there and
get a stop but it is patrick mahomes and
statistically i know that one yard we
can get right here you know let's go get
it so it was definitely a touring
decision for me
but harvest being who he is you know it
wasn't a doubt you know he knew he was
gonna get it no i know you're one of the
best running um offenses of all time 44
straight um games with at least 100
yards calais a record that uh was
achieved this past week on what i
believe uh another coach called a bs uh
play uh calais um
what did you think of what vic fangio
had to say
uh after your coach said let's go for it
with just one
play left said it would have been would
mean a lot to the team what'd you think
of the way the broncos took it
yeah i'll say this
to me i feel like i'm glad my coach is
the person i would go for you know go
and go get that because it means
something you know in this building you
know to be a part of history you know
for what we do and how hard we work you
know um you know i was on the field
saying let's get the stops and get the
ball back for office so we can go get
100 yards because it means something you
know that's something that uh it's a lot
of hard work a lot of people who go you
know above and beyond to be able to be
in that position to capture
and uh you know to capture a record like
that you know to be in history books
something that stood for 40 years you
know over 40 years and so that's that's
important because this game you know you
want you know it's a special game it's a
fun game a lot of great people have
played it and where you can get your
name in history you know be a part of
something like that it's special and so
for me you know i'm so glad my coach you
know the kind of guy that would go for
it because to me
you know uh you know this team you know
just just being a part of something you
know you want to be a part of something
special and you know i mean obviously we
have bigger goals than that but that is
something that's definitely uh you know
it's cool to be a part of and of course
you know you you're not three and one
going for a four in one record against
the colts if not for your kicker right
like you've got to give it up for your
kicker because we just skipped right
around that 66 yard field goal
in detroit class what was your
perspective on that one
what was you know uh i see tuck in
practice you know and i'm like man this
guy has such an incredible leg and like
he's like just the nerves of steel i
mean he's an incredible
incredible person you know an incredible
football player and just see you know
when we got that ball and jeremy
walker's cut it
and uh you know i mean obviously you
know we're like get out of bounds get a
bounce and he goes down and so we have
to you know spike it real quick and you
know i'm thinking to myself like uh all
right you know you know uh we've shown a
couple times you know in games where we
just go get extra six seven yards and he
took that away so he had to throw it
away so now i'm like you know this this
is a long kick you know i think
we got tucked though it's just good
right here this is enough we can kick it
from here and i just told myself you
know because i block for him so just
give him a little more time because he's
gonna take a little bigger step
and uh just seeing that ball you know
flowing through the air and hitting that
upright or you know hitting the goal
post and bouncing in the air like your
heart stops for a second it's like wow
and i mean i didn't even know how long
it was i knew it was close to the record
but i didn't even know it was a record
to afterwards
but you know just it's great having
you know um somebody like tucker you
know just uh you know just you know
incredible football player you know
probably the best ever at his position
you know and and much respect to all the
great kickers that come before him you
know and you know and it's you know some
arguable you know conversation but you
know i'm a little biased because he's my
teammate yeah but i mean what he did
right there you know definitely put him
in the conversation for being the best
ever you know i just even in all this
and i do want to ask you about the cults
before you go uh you've had a
a full season in the first month it
seems i mean not just just walking this
through this with you right here you've
jammed an entire season's worth of drama
in just four weeks that's incredible you
know when you're three and one tested
battle tested you know we're learning
how to win tough ball games
and building our confidence which i
think is crucial for where we want to go
all right so what is the challenge for
the colts for you at the colts carson
wentz with the banged up ankles but they
come off a win that kid from wisconsin
comes downhill fast uh what what do you
what do you got for me on that front
class
team complete team that has uh you know
it has every piece you need to win ball
games uh desperate trying to get back
into the into the to the fight
um you know talent everywhere you know
um i mean
the running game they have literally
four running backs
who you have to respect that can you
know can take it for a home run at any
given time you know people forget about
wilkins but he's a good player too you
know i've played against you know all of
them multiple times being in the same
division for a couple years
and um you know i i nothing but respect
for all the running backs but it starts
with you know uh uh with taylor you know
he's a beast and um you know what he did
last week was i mean it was it was
special you know i mean it's
just he really put the team on his back
a little bit in my opinion uh you know
then carson wentz stepped up and and
uh had his best game as a cult uh but
i've played against carson wentz
multiple times as well that's right and
uh with him you know he's a competitor
and so it's gonna be uh this will take
all of us to take you know our best
effort you know because this team the
way their defense is too you know
they're just a talented team and uh
they're starting to get it rolling so
you know it's going to take our a game
well look class i know i've kept you on
the phone a long time during uh uh
middle of a week on practice day but i i
i always want to give you the chance to
tell us what's going on in your world
with the
with your charitable works and your
works in the community you're walter
payton man of the year award winner you
got that patch on your jersey which not
everybody a very few people have it's
the best patch in the nfl
um and i know that there's a c patch for
a lot of people too uh what is going on
in your world that you might want people
to be a part of calais
yeah you know i mean honestly uh it's
just um you know
getting out in the community getting to
know baltimore you know uh getting out
in some of the recreation centers
and uh schools and uh trying to just um
you know arm them with with tools you
know being you know teaming up with the
the ravens and uh passing out laptops uh
the last couple weeks you know trying to
you know
fight the digital divide
uh you know um obviously uh it's just
one of those things where you know
giving away uh laptops and um and um
internet service and then i just you
know trying to do my part as a mentor
and talking to kids and stuff but uh you
know it's always fun you know when when
you can go out and get in the community
and put a smile on the kids faces man i
take great pride in that it's a great
honor to be a role model in this
community you're the best kalayas
campbell thank you for the time let's
stuck let's uh let's stay in touch what
a what a season you've had so far
appreciate it thank you for the call
rich it's always a pleasure man right
back at you that is calais campbell
prior to the colts on monday night
football
right here on the rich eisen show
oh baby hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here